توج وزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتونوبلنكن
سلسله الزيارات الامريكيه الى رام الله
هذا الشهر بداها مستشار الامن القومي ثم
مديره وكاله الاستخبارات السيائيه المطلب
الامريكي من الفلسطينيين هو التهدئه
والثمن وعد بالحفاظ على مبدا حل الدولتين
واعاده فتح القنصليه الامريكيه في القدس
الشرقيه و 50 مليون دولار الى جانب توفير
خدمه الجيل الرابع للانترنت وغيرها
في هذه الاثناء نحن نعرض اي اجراء من جانب
اي طرف لجعل حل دولتين صعب المنال ونحن
كنا واضحين ان هذا يشمل اجراءات كتوسيع
المستوطنات وتشريع البؤر الاستيطانيه
واعمال هدم البيوت واخلاء المنازل من
سكانها وتغيير الوضع القائم التاريخي في
الاماكن المقدسه
الوعود والزيارات الامريكيه لرام الله
تبدو مرضيه نوعا مال السلطه الفلسطينيه
بعد قطيعه اداره ترامب لكن ليست كافيه
فيرىى الفلسطينيون ضروره ان تترجم الى
خطوات عمليه على الارض لعوده المسار
التفاوضطي لذلك سلموا الاداره الامريكيه
ورقه من 12 بندا ابرازها ان تتوقف اسرائيل
عن اقتحام المدن وتوسيع المستوطنات وتغيير
الوضع التاريخي والديني في القدس
للعمل مع الاداره الامريكيه
والمجتمع الدولي لعوده الحوار السياسيه من
اجل الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
عمليات من جانب الاداره الامريكيه لتنفيذ
ايلتزام من هذه الالتزامات منزل تسلم هذه
الاداره وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه طلب من
القياده الفلسطينيه اعاده التنسيق الامني
مع اسرائيل والحد من انتشار المجموعات
المسلحه وبسط السيطره الامنيه والمضيء
بالاصلاحات القانونيه نتائج زياره بلينكن
للمنطقه ستظهر بعد انتهائها مباشره ان
كانت اسرائيل ستوقف اقتحامات المدن وبناء
المستوطنات وهدم المنازل ام ان وزراء
حكومه نتنياهو من اليمين المتطرف سيواصلون
مغامره تكون نتائجها دمويه كما حدث في
الشهر الاول من هذا العام عبد الحفيظ
جعوان العربيه الاراضي الفلسطينيه